stephen strange  the illuminati will see you now  we will see what kind of doctor strange  you are  marvel studios doctor strange rated p  strange it's time  in 10 days  nothing can prepare you  for the truth  everything you've ever known led you to  this moment  stephen strange the illuminati will see  you now  marvel studios dr strange ready pg-13  see it in premium large format in imax  may 6th  the multiverse it's dangerous  i could use an avenger  it's about time you showed up  on may 6th  enter a world  of strange try not to break the  multiverse stephen  oh come on  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  pg-13 you can see it in premium large  format in imax tickets on sale now  you